l'équipe si tutu tool vous emmène sur
brut en direct du clip la loi de la
calle
pour que ça marche mais je fais juste ça
pour une fière ça fait partie de
nombreux gens qui sont rassembleur il a
une légitimité officieux on aurait même
donné il a craché son 55e rappeur romand
du temps j'ai clamé sexy comme la grotte
de saint satur kardashian contre agen 23
millions système j'ai pas 20 ans nos
seniors j'étais content ça fait
longtemps j'avais content que j'ai pas
compté dans mon siège de l'étranger
[Musique]
tron l'enfermement
blague à part
toi tu peux me montrer que la voiture
pensez quoi de ce clip pour l'instant
réalisé par william thomas
il est comment la grâce à ces gens
[Musique]
là pour le coup on peut dire que jackass
et des nippes là je me suis dit
ah ouais c'est le proco jul et je fais
moi des gens qui
jouent les profs excuse moi c'est
peut-être que chez ce que je vais faire
maintenant
j'annonce dire qu il ya un an william
hague
brooks déjà la fin de même organisé le
premier marché je pense que vous l'avez
déjà
vu des gens d'être tu vois et on avait
parlé il ya des liens qui était fait
encore froid et un beau jour être
conforme en iran - les gazons faire le
marseille paris et du coup je trouvais
l'idée
écrit sonel jean mais parfois ils sont
venus en tout cas pour le g c'est qu'il
respecte les jets qui savent qu'ils vont
fallait vraiment une personne car
qu'approuver vraiment chose qu'à le
respect qu'on a pour le gie pour pouvoir
réunir tu vois tous ces interdits c'est
toujours plaisir coupable
la croyance
j'espère
la bonne énergie avec la musique
j'ai tapé le gifam
il lui pose la question je t ai pas vus
par un mur au bout oui non mais jérôme
ce que oui oui oui le
crac c'était l'armée parce que jouer
contre lui les choses changent a regagné
jeudi que jamais moi je les frappe et
il va prendre m le gym a tapé va
sûrement brut
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
a font vite commencé
mais poursuivent les rafales de bauchi
saison à 200 avec les sens sur le ferry
sait tous les pitots les coupons dans
des cachalots dans ton corps s'affiche
pas le genou droit que le guen comptent
par
[Musique]
dizaines
je pense que c'est tout ce qu'on aime
voir je sais à la base faut pas oublier
que c'est une musique avait énormément
de mal à se faire entendre
dans les années 90 il ya eu un gros boum
dans les années 2000 mais voilà faut
être conscient que c'est une musique qui
vient qui vient de la rue qui vient des
quartiers aujourd'hui on a la chance de
faire de la musique populaire et de
faire montrer à la france que
paris marseille on peut être unie et on
peut faire de belles choses merci à tous
ceux qui a accepté la demande de venir
ce projet tous les parisiens même les
marseillais et relance une idée qui est
voilà qui met une conscience sur les
routes est et j'ai réussi à la faire le
projet ses fins de mois pile pour
organiser ça en fait j'ai beaucoup aussi
écouter quand j'ai fait le truc des
choix des prod j'ai beaucoup écouté les
rappeurs que ce soit commuée du coup du
connus ou moins connus
j'ai écouté pour voir s'il allait d'un
certain
certains délires de proto soirée j'ai
essayé de faire mon maximum
que tout le monde se sente bien tu vois
le but c'est pas de jeu vous car poil ni
de faire mieux ni deux ni les sous ni le
but c'est l'union parce que j'assure les
organiser l'idée c'était de répartir les
revenus équitables là c'est pareil moi
je n'ai pas de recul sur sa selle sur ce
point comme moi
je sais pas le nombre de ventes en
première semaine
je sais pas du tout
ce que tu as fait une tour de circuit
est un circuit d'ajouter
j'ai encore réunion
je
veux bien mais vous vous le promets la
salle saint-thomas
[Musique]
à plus d'un
demain plumtree crise
c'est les grands projets saas et craint
pas trop menacés pour les
parce que tu sais un petit peu à un
crédit temps et comme j'ai eu l'heur de
d'enchaînements studio n'ait eu le temps
de faire trois vraies faut que je joue
en mode 2 3 pourquoi te faut trottier
incroyable
devant abidal c'est soit des détonations
souvent des 10
moi pour le mairie se sont réconciliés
que ça tu meurs
placé en dessous de cette réunion mais
la caméra on va être le truc c'est bon
juste la phrase de corse quand il parle
de toi on voit votre avis je lui ai pas
fait appel il va mettre sur le corps de
cos a
vite été retrouvés dans deux très grands
moments de jura français avec
réorganiser et là le clasico qu'est ce
que ça représente pour toi de te
retrouves l'impression et la pression
c'est l'organisation sédition et
plusieurs artistes etc des projets
ambitieux en fait ce projet ambitieux et
c'est cool déjà mersiol parce que c'est
une histoire
ses jambes lourdes du parti de m
chaud près de l'ess du roi
mangent les féculents entrants j'étais
pas
il fait le macaire il faut ça devenait
très grands volets
wesh régissant le cros mollet
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde sort ça tout ce luxe pas
facile non